all right so there's a new home alone
coming out they're rebooting remaking
home alone they're doing it over again
because this is what we're doing now
just taking every movie that was in the
90s and redoing it which is more
evidence of course that Hollywood has
run out of ideas which we already knew
but the bigger question for me if you're
doing an updated version of home alone
how are you gonna get around the fact
that modern technology exists which was
already sort of a problem for the first
one even though yes cellphones didn't
really have cellphones back in the early
90s but you did have phones and my
memory of that movie is somehow the
mother never thought to just call the
kid on the phone and talk to him it's
been a while since I've seen it but she
never she just never calls him but then
had if you have cellphones now how are
you it seems like this would be a
12-minute movie that would end with
Kevin wakes up he's realizes that he's
been left calls his mom on on the cell
phone she says oh crap we forgot you
turn it around now they come back
credits roll end of movie and you know
what if that's if that's what they do if
it's a 12-minute movie which ends with a
cell phone call being made I would
respect that because that's gritty
that's realistic if you're going for
gritty realism which is a thing nowadays
then I think why not really why not
really do it all right
much to discuss today including Media
Matters compiling a greatest hits
compilation for The Daily wire which we
all really appreciate we're gonna talk
about that I'll play some of it but
before we do that we have to talk about
something quite a bit more serious there
was another there was another and maybe
you didn't hear about this one but there
was another mass killing last night
this one though isn't getting as much
media attention and there's a pretty
obvious reason why we'll get into that
in a second talk about why this one is
being ignored but first before we do
that a quick word from our friends at
dynatrap dynatrap indoor fly light it's
it's summer you know there's nothing
more annoying in summer than having bugs
and everything invading your home it's a
problem what do you do about it and when
you've got bugs and you've got germs
you've got disease you've got filth what
do you do about that that's why we like
to thank our sponsors over at dynatrap
dynatrap is the leading manufacturer of
outdoor mosquito and insect traps and
now they've come up with a
Ellucian for indoor pests the dynatrap
fly light the dynatrap fly light works
day and night to attract and trap flies
fruit flies mosquitoes other insects
whatever the problem is this will take
care of it and it really does work
forget about those sticky strips or
whatever whatever barbaric instrument
you're using to get rid of bugs forget
about that the dynatrap fly light looks
like a subtle nightlight that plugs into
any indoor outlet easiest cake trust me
I've been using the dynatrap fly light
for weeks now and it has pretty much
taken care of whatever pest problem we
would otherwise have in the house during
the summer so get yours at dynatrap calm
that's Dyn ATR AP comm enter the promo
code walsh receive 15% off any of their
products dynatrap the safe silent and
simple solution to household insect
control alright so Garden Grove
California about 30 or so miles outside
of downtown LA that was the site last
night of a mass killing spree that left
four people dead four people killed at
random by a mass murdering scumbag
so this would be the third mass killing
incident in America this week yet this
particular one isn't getting the same
kind of attention as the others and why
is that well my guess would be that it's
partly because of the weapon of choice
he didn't use a gun he used a knife and
for that reason this has gotten as I
said not a ton of attention this morning
for example I was perusing a few of the
new sights for some reason once NBC NBC
news calm and it this this didn't even
make above-the-fold on the website it
wasn't even one of their if you go to
you know you go to the website the first
few stories you see at the top wasn't at
the top yet to scroll down six or seven
stories to get to this the reason for
the media to de-emphasize this story is
obvious it doesn't fit the narrative
it's not something they can use to
advance a political agenda but it's
still an important story because four
people died four people were stabbed to
death as this
guy went around town attacking random
potestas pedestrians it's a brutal
horrible story that certainly is
newsworthy one would think and it shows
it demonstrates a truth that I think we
all need to understand and it's it's
because of this that the media ignores
it but what it shows is you know the
minute someone decides that they want to
kill mass numbers of people and they
don't care if they live or die in the
process this guy did live he was
arrested but they don't care if they
live or die they don't care if they go
to jail so they don't care about the
consequences and they want to kill a lot
of people the minute a person gets to
that state psychologically and
spiritually there is basically no law no
law in the world that could stop them
from hurting people there's no law
that's going to do it the minute someone
makes that decision now it's it's
unlikely the government wants us to feel
otherwise but it's it's unlikely that
you have ever been saved from being a
victim in one of these kinds of
incidents by a law you know what I mean
is it's unlikely that you were ever in a
situation where a person would have hurt
you or shot you stabbed you whatever but
for laws preventing them it that's
that's probably not the case the reason
why you hopefully have never been shot
or stabbed unless you have been but the
reason if you haven't been the reason
why you've been spared that is it's
probably just because nobody ever
seriously wanted to hurt you or you were
never in a place where a psychotic
killer decided you wanted to attack it's
kind of scary to think of it that way
I know we would sort of rather think
that there the government is this
all-seeing protective eye that's just
stopping all bad things from happening
maybe when we get very lazy we might we
may like to think of it that way but
that's not how it is
the one thing keeping us safe keeping
society together is the simple fact that
most people don't want to cause serious
harm to others if that ever changes then
chaos ensues now that doesn't mean there
should be no laws obviously laws serve a
purpose I'm not advocating an arc here
but the point is you this the I think
here's the point we need to think of it
this way we need to think what if my
luck runs out you know what if I what if
what if a murderous psycho ever does
come to harm me how will I protect
myself in that situation because most
likely if that happens if that murderous
psycho has his eyes set on you for
whatever reason
the only thing that will protect you in
that moment is you in that moment in
that situation you are going to be the
first last and only line of defense for
yourself and so we all need to protect
ourselves it's not paranoia it's just
being prepared it's being safe this is
the point that gun rights advocates are
trying to make it's a very reasonable
point even aside from the constitutional
issues which are important obviously
because we can't just discard the law
and the Second Amendment is law but even
even beyond that it's it's a really
reasonable point that if you're ever in
a situation and you you have no control
really over whether you'll ever be in a
situation but if you're ever in a
situation where someone does want to do
you harm in that now we could talk about
what laws and that's not all in that
moment right there all of that stuff
melts away doesn't matter doesn't matter
what laws are there it doesn't matter
what national conversations were having
it doesn't matter what what policies are
enact it doesn't matter what initiatives
we're working none of that matters in
that moment in fact the police probably
don't even matter in that moment because
they're face to face now there's they're
not going to be there in time probably
for you
so it's just can you protect yourself or
not and I think that's what we know
that's how we all need to start need to
start thinking again not it's not it's
not about being paranoid
it's just about realizing this base of
truth that when it comes down to it if
someone is coming after you
if you end up you know in the line of
sight of one of these murderous psychos
you're gonna be the only person who can
protect yourself so are you going to be
able to do that or not
all right Media Matters
the fine folks at Media Matters who are
huge supporters of this show and every
show that daily why are they they watch
all our shows every day and then we'll
frequently post highlights of the show
now of course they do it to try to whip
up outrage against us but the fact is
they're still watching the show in fact
they're watching right now so I want to
say hi to whatever Media Matters minion
is watching the show right now I want to
say hello thank you for being here glad
to have you with us help you enjoy hope
you're enjoying the show hope you enjoy
the rest of it so yesterday the Media
Matters released something that I guess
supposed to be is supposed to be some
sort of expose titled The Daily wire is
a cesspool of bigotry and hatred and it
goes through the various sins of all the
hosts on our site
including yours truly all the terrible
things we've said here's how they
introduced the report it says founding
by founded by editor-in-chief ben
shapiro in 2015 with funding from
fracking magnate and former ted cruz
donor ferris wilts the daily wire was
intended to be a profit generating
outlet mixing conservative opinion in
news the site regularly advocates
positions and rhetoric that are racist
sexist and disparaging of the LGBTQ
community while most of this comes from
Shapiro or Ryan Saavedra the daily
podcast hosts hosted by Matt Walsh
Michael doles and angel Andrew Klavan
also regularly employ ugly rhetoric
about minority and oppressed groups
Media Matters looked at their podcast
released on The Daily wire site since
the beginning of 2019 and found that the
site as a platform grounded in H hatred
and bigotry
below are the podcasters and examples of
their sexist racist bigoted commentary
so Ryan got it Ryan got a nice shout out
that I didn't realize that so congrats
Ryan what
in fact they so they gave him they said
that he's a bigger source of bigotry
than than me Knowles or Clavin
yeah that's not fair what follows then
is a lengthy list of a bunch of stuff
we've said stuff that's supposed to be
offensive I guess but hopefully if you
if you don't like reading they also put
together a compilation of all the hatred
and bigotry from daily wire hosts but
the hatred is much more of a highlight
reel I think sort of a greatest hits
actually I'm thinking that I'm going on
vacation in a couple weeks I'm thinking
maybe I'll hire the folks at Media
Matters
to put together a gate a couple Greatest
Hits shows for me that I can play in my
absence I don't even need to hire them
actually they'll do it for free of which
is very generous so what I want to do is
take a look at their video they say they
reviewed seven months of podcasts to put
this together so let's I think it would
be rude of me after they've done all
that work it'd be very rude of me to
ignore it and and no I want to play it
for you and and we'll go through and
take a look at it so um here we go how
is it that drag queens have escaped the
blackface backlash okay actually stop
right there
I just want to say that I'm honored that
I got to be first in the hate montage
this is my greatest professional
achievement and as for what I said that
right there I couldn't possibly you know
I said that that drag is female
blackface i i want to stipulate i could
not possibly be more right about that
it's amazing how right I am on that
point in fact going back and watching
that again it was a lot of fun to relive
my rightness amazingly right yes drag is
female blackface it is a grotesque
mockery of womanhood
absolutely I retract that not at all not
at all and in fact that's at the point I
make all the time I make it in a lot of
my speeches and it does it
people to get upset about it but I've
yet to hear anyone explain how I'm wrong
I understand that it makes your tummy
hurt it makes you upset you don't like
hearing it fine understood and I'm sorry
about that I'm sorry about your tummy
but how am I wrong it is my contention
that when you've got a man dressing up
in this absurd cartoonish costume
pretending to be a woman I think that
that is demeaning to women I think it
makes a caricature of womanhood how am I
wrong it seems to me that being the drag
that's exactly what that's exists that's
pretty much the definition of drag
making a caricature of womanhood that's
exactly what you're doing it's certainly
not realistic I've never have you ever
seen a woman a real woman who dresses
like like a drag queen dresses you ever
seen that no so what the what the drag
queen is basically telling us is like
this is how they see womanhood and they
see it in a very insulting and degrading
light so yeah I'm 100% right about that
let's go back to the clip the very fact
that women wear leggings tells you
something the female body is made to
attract Planned Parenthood is the is a
rapist best friend now isn't there a
difference between standing up for
integration standing up for the right of
black people to move into a community
once they can afford it jew-hating
congresswoman Ilan Omar transgender
women aren't women love is love or if it
feels good do it as a result of this the
logical conclusion is we're gonna
normalize pedophilia is obviously one
the same sex marriage battle do you
think that they're going to win the
redefinition of sex battle as well if
they win that battle then it really is
over Western civilization is over at
that point the West broadly invented
every single thing that's ever been
invented but and made virtually every
discovery that has ever been discovered
personally I agree with Tucker Carlson
and Donald Trump that you should not be
allowed in the country if you think it
stinks feminism has created this
generation of women who think they
matter because they're women who think
their ideas matter because they're women
because think their ideas are protected
because they're women they're not
alright just want to say i disavow i
disavow that sexism from andrew Clavin
how dare he suggest that women should be
judged based on their personal
individual merits and not given credit
just simply for being women how dare he
suggest that how dare he am I doing this
right
alright go back but women have their own
advantages mainly they have their
sexuality and they have their appearance
and they have the desires of men okay
stop there again I just want to say i
disavow I disavow the sexism of that
strange homeless man talking to himself
in his car I am disgusted that he would
say Jess
I couldn't tell cuz those sunglasses I
am disgust that he would suggest that
men are attracted to women and this is a
fact that women sometimes exploit
how dare he said I mean because no
woman's ever done that right I mean no
no woman would ever dream of exploiting
the fact that wit that men are attracted
has never happened ever and so for him
for that homeless man to even suggest
such a thing offends me personally I
think he owes an apology to women
everywhere ok let's go back to the video
if I had to choose between these 95% of
people who thrive in this Christian
setting and the 5% of gay people who are
cast out who ultimately find themselves
rejected for who they are I would
obviously choose the 95 percent over the
5 percent I think that it is worse to
slaughter babies after they've been born
than to wear blackface wait let's stop
there again did Knowles just say that
it's it's worse it's worse to kill
babies than to paint your face black
that is so outrageous
I mean Media Matters is right these
people except for me
the other two these these people are
dangerous for I mean what for him to say
that it's worse to kill a human being
than to paint your face certain color
what where is this guy coming from I can
see why that made it into the montage I
mean it's not like that's a totally
innocuous statement that any civilized
person on the planet would agree with
that's no no no this is this is really
controversial stuff abortion helps
rapists cover up their crimes you are
just not a decent person if you support
giving lethal injection to infants
abortion doctor number four is a
problematic term because it includes the
word doctor I would suggest the term
medical assassin there is obviously
something wrong in that house of Islam
there is a lot more evidence that Ilhan
Omar has sympathies for al-qaeda then
there is the Donald Trump is a racial
vigor my joke about her was she was so
angry she almost exploded but the TSA
took the belt off you when you come out
of a hellscape like Somalia and America
takes you in nurtures you elevates you
to Congress and you don't feel grateful
for that you there is something terribly
terribly wrong with you she supports
Sharia law which I think is the dividing
line between Muslims we can live with
and Muslims we can't live with but the
question of whether it's inherently
violent is important it's certainly not
a religion of peace it's a religion this
cancerous that anti-jewish ideology is
an ideology being embraced by Ilan Omar
and Rashida to leave aoc is an ignoramus
Rasheeda Talib is an anti-semite Ilan
Omar also anti-semite they deserve all
the attacks they deserve all the trouble
they're getting from the top 14 major
Wars going on in the world right now of
the top 14 13 of them involve Islam
these movements students for justice and
Palestine are which is a one of the most
ironically named groups because it's
it's not led by students it isn't about
justice and there's no such country as
Palestine all right I just need to
interrupt here again and say that that
in all seriousness here it's it's been
it's been 90 seconds and I haven't been
featured at all and that seems unfair to
me it seems unfair that Knowles and
Clavin get their bigotry featured for a
minute and a half and I'm ignored that
is truly truly hurtful Media Matters
especially because I guess that was
supposed to be a whole chunk of them
insulting AOC and Ilhan Omar I've
insulted them too so what you didn't
what my insults weren't good enough to
make it in that part of the the hate
montage pretty hurtful that cuts deep no
I I don't think that till Abe it has
dual loyalty because there's no evidence
at all that she's loyal to America in
the first place immigrants today though
it's a very different situation they are
not building the country because it's
already built and oftentimes they're not
even interested in being part of our
culture they want to come here and do
their own thing from promulgated that
whole birther nonsense and it was
nonsense but I didn't think that was
racist either that's a fantasy the
fantasy that Trump is making racism
worse that he's bringing out from under
the rock all the evil white supremacist
the white supremacism is a growing
problem which the numbers show that it
is not white males of today are not
allowed to look back in history and
admire or enjoy the work of other white
males the point is making that
civilization has come from Europe is
true I read his manifesto the great
replacement it was called because he is
objecting to the fact that immigrants of
color and it wasn't necessarily Islam he
didn't sound friendly to Jews or anybody
else he said he believed in white people
need to find people white people as
people of European descent okay so there
we have Clavin simply describing
reporting what was in a manifesto I I
can't even figure out how I really I
actually can't figure out how that made
it in there I feel like they're trying
to pad Clavin stats a little bit by
putting stuff like that in there which
really isn't fair you said a few things
that I mean come on how does that how
does that make it in the in the montage
at all all right let's so we got a few
more minutes let's watch the rest of
this where he says how is Barack Obama
black he's also white it's also a fair
point you will see illegal aliens waving
the Mexican flag if you want to live
under the Mexican flag go back to Mexico
multiculturalism is a implausible
implausible philosophy it cannot be
cannot be the cultures that enslave
people that cultures the treat women
like trash that those cultures are equal
to cultures that do not that cannot be
that was one of the things that was kind
of lost in the in the whole meet to
hysteria there were also plenty of cases
where you looked at it it was pretty
apparent that the women were also
culpable feminists are insecure about
the fact that they themselves are not
men just you know hysteria that we found
in the me2 movement is that it engenders
suspicion so if we don't say that hey
this Chelsea Manning was actually
bradley manning at the time and if we
call it her and say she were being
polite we're not being hurtful now I'll
call anybody anything where they want to
be called I really will I'll call him
the king of Romania I don't care all
right let's stop again because see this
is what I'm talking about
Clavin says that that he'll call people
whatever they want to be called how did
that make it in the mizzen that exactly
what he's what we're supposed to say
isn't that just being respectful how did
that make it in does he work for Media
Matters or something I think that Andrew
Clavin works for media matters and
that's why he put a lot of his own stuff
in here and featured himself patted his
bigotry stats I'm starting to get
suspicious okay there's conspiracies now
are floating around in my head because
that doesn't make any sense to me
alright we got let's let's play the last
minute of this trip down memory lane
this is especially true in these hot
button social issues like transgenderism
where you could face social consequences
if you speak obvious truths you could
speak professional code you can face
professional consequences if you speak
obvious truths you can cut your body
into 17 different pieces you still will
not change your gender every cell you
have is of a specific gender people are
so desperate to be included to be
included in the supposedly oppressed
LGBT category that they're making up
label labels that make no sense just so
they can be included just goes to show
you that this is not an oppressed group
in fact it shows you that the opposite
is the case
it shows you that this is a privileged
group Pride Month now it's about gender
it's about sexual identity so now there
aren't just two genders there are 56
different genders these gay activists
are out there prowling like lions
waiting for these kids to come and tell
them there's that their religion your
religion rejects you there is no God
your family rejects you families stink
the patriarchy stinks marriage is
between a man and a woman no amount of
social engineering is going to change
that so if we're talking about two gay
men adopting a child so you think the
mothers we just you know we didn't need
a mother a man cannot function as a
mother he thinks that a man can be a
woman and a woman can be a man just
because he puts on lipstick if you put
on lipstick then you're a woman but of
course that's not what makes a woman so
if marriage is going to be anything and
if it's going to have any purpose
whatsoever then it must be a union
between a man and a woman so there you
go by the way elephant in the room here
why isn't Ben in the montage at all what
I mean come on was Media Matters just I
guess they were trying to give the rest
of us a chance to shine which which
which I appreciate that I I guess pretty
pretty thoughtful but a little bit a
little bit surprising now if it's if
it's possible to find anything serious
to say about what we just watch together
it is pretty revealing that the the
leftist minions at Media Matters
selected those clips okay and they put
them all together without explaining why
they're offensive that's what's funny
here is that they it's they don't go
into any any explanation they just show
us the clips assuming that the clips are
so offensive that they don't even need
to explain why they're offensive they
think it just speaks for itself it's
self-evident that this is this is
offensive stuff meanwhile most people
are gonna watch most of that I mean I
don't want to put words in your mouth or
tell you how you feel about it but I'm
I'm guessing most of the people watching
right now or listening when you hear
that montage you're that you probably
your thought was something like okay
hey because most of that is just really
an oculus and and pretty self-evident so
it shows how we're living we really are
living in to forget about lit but about
living in two separate countries some
people say this country has become so
divided ideologically that it's like two
separate countries or or even or more
countries you know if maybe it's
fractured even more than that but I I
think it's worse than living in two
separate countries it seems to me that
we're living in two separate universes
we are just living in two separate
realities that's how far apart we are if
you could watch that montage and come
away truly offended by most of what you
heard there and shocked and appalled by
it then you you're you're living and
you're living in some other universe I I
can't even you're living in a universe
where basic fundamental truth is
offensive and that's what makes the
divide in our country now that's what
makes it so much more severe and and and
so much worse than times past I've said
before and I believe that we are more
divided now than we were during the
Civil War it's significantly more
divided and I don't think that I'm not
saying I think we're actually going to
have another Civil War I don't think we
will for any number of reasons one being
that the divide is not exactly precisely
geographical like it was back then
there are geographical elements to it
but it's not it's not quite as clean as
it was then and and and other reasons
too I just don't I don't I don't see
that happening but ideologically
culturally I think we are there's a
there's a greater divide because even
back in the Civil War they disagreed
obviously on some very important issues
and I think even more significant than
that as far as what caused the war to
happen was the cultural there are two
very different cultures in the north and
in the South in
culture of the north the agrarian you
know culture the south but they still
agreed on really fundamental things
there was a fundamental agreement on
things like objective truth there is a
God very objective morality
now they disagreed on what was moral and
what wasn't notably the issue of slavery
so there were substantial disagreements
in the realm of morality but they both
at least agreed that objective morality
is a thing that exists so if you can get
there at least when both sides who are
arguing over something can at least
agree that yeah morality exists it's a
thing but now let's argue about whether
or not this particular thing is moral
well at least there there's some hope of
eventually reaching an agreement but if
you can't even agree that objective
morality is a thing in the first place
then your argument can go nowhere so
those that's that's our divide has gone
much deeper than divides in the past and
this is just one minor example but
[Music]
that's I think that's the trouble all
right Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com is the email
address take a look at some emails this
is from Peter says hello supreme leader
Walsh I hope this email finds you well
and the glory of my beard will at least
grant me the blessing of a quick death
when your regime comes despite the fact
that I am about to attempt to enlighten
your already all-knowing magnificence I
agree with your overall take on
videogames and their desensitizing
effect on the mind even though I'm a
pretty avid gamer myself the dirty
secret is that I believe the vast
majority of other gamers would also
probably agree with your general take
that children of a certain age should
cap their amount of time playing games
and hyper ghor artificial though it may
be obviously doesn't have a positive
psychological effect on a still molding
mind that just to stop you there that's
interesting so you're telling me that
makes me feel a little bit better you're
telling me that that this is according
to you maybe you're wrong but it's your
feeling based on your converse a
with other gamers that most gamers would
actually agree with a lot of what I've
said even if they won't say it so that
makes me feel a little bit better
because I you know that was the
frustrating thing for me we're talking
about this video game thing I yes I'm
biased in favor of my own points but I
do feel like most of the points I've
made are pretty obvious it's it's hard
for me to believe there could be
disagreement things like it's it's not
it's not healthy for a kid to spend
hours and hours a day playing video
games he should do other things like go
outside and be in the fresh air and
things like if a kid is exposed to hyper
as you say hyper ghor really really
violent video games for four hours a day
starting early and childhood that
probably will have a psychological
impact to me those two propositions are
arts are extremely obvious shouldn't be
controversial and so what you're saying
is you think most gamers would actually
agree though maybe they well I'll read
the rest of what you're saying the thing
is that now I'm not going to read the
rest of it I'll just tell you what
you're saying I will do that the thing
is that that measured that measure take
is usually not the stance held by the
media or politicians alike no matter
what side of the aisle they're on ever
since the 90s videogames have always
been one of the major boogeyman that
gets tried it out after shooting and put
up as a main cause right next to the
Second Amendment so this over
defensiveness of gamers is a reflexive
response established over literal
decades to the regular vilification of
our favorite hobby it's like how
Republicans will say that Trump does no
wrong to the press even though they
might not like something he tweeted or
said it's showing a united front against
a perceived enemy coming into our
territory especially since the
overreaction could even lead to
ridiculous regulations in are still
relatively untouched fear of
entertainment I know this isn't how you
think but was just giving what hoping to
give some perspective on this
controversial topic well that was
helpful that was a helpful help of
helpful perspective you started by
saying you were going to disagree with
me but I don't think you disagreed at
all you're just giving the perspective
of trying to explain maybe why some
gamers are reluctant to have this
conversation and I understand you
you make the comparison to Donald Trump
and I think that's an apt comparison
because you say that you're the
Republicans and conservatives who
disagree with a lot of what Trump says
but in public they'll they'll defend it
and because they're trying to show
United Front I I could say for sure I
know that's the case because iíve been
in green rooms alright
I've been in green rooms with with
people who are sitting there complaining
about what Trump said and then they go
on TV and defend it so I and anyone
who's in media we've all pin in that we
all know in media we all know the
conversations we have behind the scenes
and I just I'll just tell you that I've
talked to a lot of people in the
conservative media space and things like
Trump's tweeting almost there's
agreement among almost everybody that
it's stupid and he needs to stop a lot
of it but they won't say it publicly a
lot of them and I I can understand the
thought process
United Front and all that and you don't
want to say something that's gonna be
exploited by by by the the other side as
it were but I still think that number
one we can't forfeit truth i if we do
that even if it seems like a small truth
if we forfeit truth and honesty then I
really don't see the point of anything
anymore so this isn't a sermon or a
homily on my part I really I honestly do
not see I I do not see the point if
we're gonna say well let's not be honest
let's not be truthful let's pretend to
hold views we don't actually have for
the sake of winning well I could dispute
whether or not that's actually an
effective strategy I don't think it is
but even if it were I don't what are we
fighting for the thing that gets me up
every morning the thing that motivates
me is that I feel like I'm fighting for
truth you know and
if that's not it if we're giving that up
and say yeah it doesn't matter that
doesn't matter as much then I don't see
the point I don't even know why I'm
doing this I might as well just go work
it you know I might as well just leave
this and go work at Jiffy Lube or
something it's just why why do this
so even something like video games I you
know if you agree that there are some
issues with video games and things like
we should we should parent not the
government parents should regulate how
much time the kids spend playing video
games things like that I think you
should say so publicly for for no other
reason then it's it's the honest thing
to do and if that's if that's not enough
to motivate us then I also think you
know coming across as less reasonable
than you really are I don't think that's
an effective debating strategy so what
do you have gamers that did not at least
publicly well even if they feel
differently in their heads who publicly
deny that there's anything wrong with
video games at all or they could have
any negative impact well you just come
across as unreasonable and people are
gonna take you less seriously so if
we're not worried about the the moral
aspect of being dishonest and what about
this I think coming across as
unreasonable as incapable of nuanced
thinking I don't think that ultimately
helps I think it's gonna what it leads
to whether we're talking about gamers or
Trump fans or any any category of people
when they pretend to be less reasonable
than they are they pretend that they
can't understand nuanced arguments I
think what that leads to is people
aren't gonna take you seriously anymore
and they're not gonna listen to what you
have to say see I've been at this point
with with a lot of gamers honestly this
week that I've gotten tons of emails and
messages and things from from from
people who play video games and 90% of
them are so unreasonable that it makes
me want to tune it out and say I don't
what anywhere people have to say I can't
cuz I can't talk to you now I hear from
someone like you Peter and it makes me
say okay well here's a reasonable person
I'm so glad that's why I'm talking in
our 20 minutes I'm just so it's so
refreshing I can talk to a reasonable
person about this so I think being
reasonable I think I think is not only
the morally correct choice but
ultimately I think it helps us whatever
your cause may be I think it helps your
cause all right this is from LD sis
hello Matt you're a fan of calling
things stupid and cowardly
well you rant about white supremacy your
your rant about white supremacy and
anti-semitism yesterday white supremacy
anti-semitism in scare quotes for there
was stupid and cowardly these are hoaxes
perpetuated by the left to slander
conservatives you play right into their
hands by panicking about these boogie
men disappointed okay
LD I agree that the left slanders
conservatives as white supremacist and
white nationalist and racist and I talk
about that all the time and I am
obviously opposed to that and those
labels don't have the impact they once
did because they are so often misused
and that's something that a lot of us
have been trying to explain to the left
for a while now that when you go around
calling everybody that anyone who
disagrees with you as a racist well what
you've made it is so that when you
actually encounter a real racist you
have nothing left to say about them that
will have any impact because you've
already used that word a million times
where it didn't apply and so it's the
old boy who cried wolf situation so
that's that's that's all true but to
suggest that white nationalist racists
don't exist is obviously absurd that
they do exist they've been coming after
me all week okay I can report they exist
talk to Ben you know Ben has 24-hour
security followed him around because of
these people because of the threats that
he gets so I you know LD I'm gonna I'm
gonna
do you the favor of assuming that you
just don't know what you're talking
about and maybe you don't because you
haven't you haven't encountered these
people you haven't come up against them
and so you you just don't know but I'm
telling you they exist they are very
real and Ben is not the only media
figure who needs security around the
clock because of them that's not a joke
that's that's real and they are some of
the most vile creatures on earth without
without e it's not even close I can tell
you it's not even close what comes to
hate mail and stuff that I get the the
the most disgusting vile hate mail
talking about my family you know
personal stuff the majority of it comes
from these types these types who you say
don't even exist well am i hallucinating
we're all just hallucinating here well
I'll tell you what's not a hallucination
is the three mass shootings over 80
people have died in three mass shooting
events perpetrated by people who
specifically were motivated by white
nationalists talking points they all
specifically stated that they were
committing these acts to advance the
white nationalist cause three mass
shootings in eight months how many do
you need that's what I asked yesterday
do you need 10 need 15 20 30 so it's a
real question how many do you need
before you're willing to admit that yes
they're real and they're a problem 80
people dead in 8 months that's not
enough for you an average of 10 a month
not enough what do you need you need you
need 90 100 800 just give me a number
give me the number give me the body
count white nationalists are a small
group yes they're a fringe group yes but
they are loud their vocal they are scum
and every once in a while they go out
and murder dozens of people the
suggestion that we should just ignore
them and pretend they don't exist well
well what else do I call that but stupid
and cowardly you're right I am a fan of
those two words because there's so much
stupid and cowardly stuff happening and
here's an example
maybe I should say stupid or cowardly I
think if you're gonna if you really
think that they don't exist or they're
not an issue then I think that's just
stupidity on your part if you know they
exist and that they're out killing
people and you say we still still
shouldn't talk about then you're a
coward
so those are the two options
listen goes without saying but if if
there had been three of the deadliest
mass shootings in history totaling 80 80
casualties over the last few months
perpetrated by antifa members then uld
and every conservative would be
screaming about it at the top of your
lungs and I know you're gonna say well
Dayton Ohio that was an antifoam ever
sure it was and what our conservatives
do when they're screaming about it and
for good reason even though look there
there is and the fact is that shooter
was a radical left winger that's a fact
that's a fact that should be discussed
it's a relevant fact it is it is a it is
also a fact that we know that if you
know if he were a Trump fan and all this
stuff the media would be plastering that
everywhere they're not with in this case
and that's for political reasons and
that's dishonest
so that's all true it's also true and it
can't be denied
that there is a distinction between the
El Paso shooter the Dayton shooter in
that we know that the El Paso shooter
was specifically doing this for
political reasons to advance his his
evil ideology which is white nationalism
we know that he was very clear about
that
now the Dayton shooter as it stands
right now we don't know his motives it's
it's right now it seems very possible
that he happened to be a left-wing
lunatic but this was a demand killed his
own sister so it seems like this could
have been a domestic thing and the
politics were unrelated or only
tangentially related and that's you know
maybe that's another one of those truths
I'm supposed to just pretend I don't
notice or it's a distinction I'm
supposed to pretend I can't see you know
in order to be a good
player but that's a that's that's that's
the reality and what I'm saying is if in
the past eight months there have been
three massive mass shootings like I said
it's 3 of the worst in history have been
carried out by these people in 8 months
if there had been 3 mass shootings to
that level in the last eight months
perpetrated by identify members who
wrote manifestos saying they were doing
this in order to advance the ante for
cause you would have conservatives
saying you know what we need to shut
down every antifa group we need to
arrest all of them it needs to be we did
next time the antifa gathers FBI needs
to show arrest them all throw them in
Guantanamo that's what conservatives
will be saying and we all know instead
what you're saying about this LD because
you are a coward is oh you know they
don't even exist these white-naped I
don't exist no I see nothing see nothing
I see nothing from Eric says hi man I'm
a huge fan of the show I just wanted to
thank you for your sobering view and
many of the tough issues as someone who
rejected almost all of my parents
attempts to get me into sports and grew
up on video games I was hoping to add as
you could tell like as I said 90% of my
my email this week has been about video
games I was hoping to add a very
different perspective to the violence of
video games topic I think people get
overly defensive of video games at the
drop of a hat due to video games
historically being blamed and attacked
on multiple occasions okay so this is a
similar point to the one I just read
I'll finish reading it though Hillary of
2005 attak advocated for regulations
against them and gamergate just to give
examples just like in the gun debate I
think there's a reflex amongst the
people who hold them dear to react very
defensively had a fear that things will
be taken away whether or not it's
justified I think this is the reaction
we're seeing I think to your point
parents to your point parents should be
should be taking over here just as you
wouldn't let a seven-year-old watch
Saving Private Ryan you shouldn't let
them play games like Grand Theft Auto
either the only point of disagreement I
would have is that I've actually seen
research showing video games can act as
an outlet for the pent-up excitement
young boys have unlike static forms of
media such as movies and television this
was certainly true for me growing up and
my love of them allowed me to make
friends that I have had for life
yeah so I already kind of responded to
that point and it it's you know I take
your point use you also threw in that
this can it can be an outlet for
aggression
you know I've expressed my skepticism of
Studies on this issue on either side
because I think the methodology it just
it doesn't it can't really get to the
heart of the matter because we're
dealing with what motivates human
behavior and that's a really hard thing
to quantify in a study but I would have
to look at the study you're talking
about that it's a that this is a for the
research saying this is an outlet i it
would seem to me that playing video
games would be like TV a method of
suppressing the energy and excitement
and aggression of a young boy
so in outlet in that sense which isn't
really an outlet it's suppressive but I
don't see how it could replace I don't
see how could really replace it because
the energy and aggression that a young
boy has it's very physical there's a
physicality to it and that's why you see
a you know six-year-old boy like my son
just bouncing around the house literally
climbing the walls jumping over the
furniture running around I mean I've
never seen the kid walk six years I've
never seen him walk I've never seen him
walk from point A to point B well okay
unless I told him like go to bed or go
clean the room and then all of a sudden
no and then he could any almost Krauze
he's going crawls he's going so slow so
it's most my son he's either moving
literally at the pace of a of a glacier
or like continental drift he's either
going that slowly or he's running
there's no in-between um and that's
because he's full of energy and so it's
very physical and he neat and he just he
needs to get that physical energy out I
don't see how sitting stationary and
moving your thumbs could ever be a
sufficient outlet for that I think maybe
it could be like a band-aid but the kid
also is going to need to get that
physical energy out all right let's see
is there one that isn't
video game related that I could read
here nope there is okay so I think we I
think we've covered the the video game
discussion and we'll just leave it there
kind of anti-climatic end I apologize
for that thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed
welcome to my cesspool of bigotry and
hate the leftist hyenas at Media Matters
have made a seven minute video
compilation and a 2,500 word article
smearing my show and the rest of the
daily wire crew as a cesspool of bigotry
and hate because we suggested that it's
wrong to kill babies after they've been
born and that men are not women we
examine the real bigots and haters for
Media Matters all the way to Joe Biden
check it out on the Michael Noel's show